hey man it's me kevin smith and welcome
to
masters of the universe revelation
celebration where we celebrate
the writers of masters of the universe
uh revelation
now uh you've seen the rep writer of
episode one
kevin smith uh dia and me did two uh
this together me and mark did three
together
me and tim did four together and last
but not least we saved the best for last
kids i i guarantee you right now
if you've got a list of 10 favorite
lines
in revelation eric's responsible for
most of them
if not all give it up for eric ladies
and gentlemen that's so nice
it's true it's very true hello everybody
now eric i met
while working on supergirl uh eric wrote
my
first episode of supergirl yeah yeah the
one with supergirl lives it was called
and they like generally they write that
show he's he worked at supergirl how
many seasons
uh three seasons season two three and
four
i was on supergirl and my second episode
ever of the show kevin directed
um and it was when
supergirl was just starting to get into
stories with
him and himself with chris wood yeah so
we took uh
melissa benoist and chris wood to space
yeah we were all hanging out
first time we hung out with e-man how
strange man that's true man we met
chris wood together and now chris wood
is our
prince adam and our heat man um tell
them what you've written your other bona
fides
i did super girl i did a show called
legend quest on netflix
i did masters of the universe um i've uh
i've written some pilots i've written
some comic books
i did a movie called justice league
versus the fatal five which is another
animated project
but if you like this you'll probably
like that there you go
in the dc animated universe we did it
with bruce tim did a big old justice
league movie he also has like four
huge projects right now that he can't
talk about incredibly secret
i know them and they're [ __ ] huge and
stuff so eric is an
ace an absolute ace i thought i was
bringing him
to masters of the universe when i told
teddy i was like i got a
[ __ ] kid he could write it ass off he
gets it
he's one of us he's younger but he's one
of us and
teddy was like oh you talk about eric
and i was like yes how'd you know him
how did you know teddy
uh i knew teddy teddy was uh the
executive
on stranger things at least for the
first season
and my fiance is one of the producers of
stranger things so i met teddy through
the whole
comic-con circuit and all the stuff that
the stranger things cast and crew was
doing teddy was along for that emily was
along for that
and i got to plus one so and so not even
a professional setting you know
fully through at a dinner table yeah
we had dinner together right away um
eric is
fast in the time that i've known him in
this business
uh become very in demand uh and a guy
that
people love to have a board man because
he
writes it like it's his own as if he
[ __ ] created the thing that supergirl
episode he wrote
you would have thought he created the
character [ __ ] supergirl he put so
much care and love into it and if you
ever loved
any deep cuts reference to dc universe
that they ever made on supergirl
it was me it was that guy he was the
nerd bible kid he was the one the other
writers on staff were like you know
about this
comic book stuff what is this and you'd
be like oh let me tell you
i also stole so many comic books so dc
would give you
i mean they were given to the room but
then nobody wanted them but me so i
would just take them home with me and
very slowly because i didn't want to
look like weird
so it's very very slowly taking fringe
of trades
yeah um he does it for the money kids
don't [ __ ] get us wrong he's no
communist
but he does it for the love there's a
lot of love in the writing uh that eric
does and and
and i've seen it in you know uh things
that
um he was paid to write that he's not
necessarily like the world's biggest
fan of like supergirl it's not like you
were like i grew up [ __ ]
playing supergirl right i grew up
playing dc comic books right he was
bigger than the big superman
guy i didn't like the character but yeah
it wasn't like i didn't i never read
every single issue or anything and then
for masters of the universe
same thing right you're like you're
you're uh
touchstone lodestar is more the movie
than anything
the first came in anything i saw was the
dolph lundgren movie
that's uh that's why you'll see a couple
references we'll talk about in this
episode
yes anytime you see a reference to the
masses of the universe movie with the
exception of episode one
um skeletor are going to let this be our
final battle though you got a little in
there
totally but eric eric was like hey man
we're the discs of things
and we were like well i mean you know in
the movie i guess he's like wow
i know they they used them in like the
the mike young show and so they had done
like the discs and they brought them
back but i was like i gotta get some
live action stuff in so
yeah um all right so going into it
like when we um the writer's room came
together
the idea was oh it's a superman story
um and this is what happens when you
know lois lane
finds out that superman has been clark
kent all along she's been lied to
and she finds out under the worst
possible set of circumstances so for two
dc
kids that was kind of the road in
so if you're like oh my god but you're
telling a master's universe story well
masters universe while being sci-fi
fantasy
came through dc comics in 1982 was
created by mattel in 1981 by 82
dc was doing comics for for mattel
where they got to expand the lore and
one of the first things they did was
like
we're a comic book company and here we
do secret identities so how come this
guy ain't got no secret identity
and prince adam was born by way of dc
comics uh take on
on masters of the universe so you know
when we
sat down and and started writers
ruminant
so much material so many incarnations
to homage to take from
to continue and stuff like that
um but the you know the heaviest lifting
kids you'll see
episode you know i've been talking about
this since mine
every episode of this show gets better
than the last
and that's not to say any of the
previous episodes suck it's just like
when you think like oh crap what could
be better than that
the next episode two so two is better
than one three is better than two four
is better than three
five rules of the mall five and and i'll
tell you
like there's a lot of when you're a show
runner you
wind up touching every script a lot i
didn't touch eric's script
very much except to take some [ __ ] that
was
so good in it i was like there's so much
good [ __ ] in it
i'm gonna take this huge chunk of good
[ __ ] and
stick it in six what are you saying is
the script was too long
that that now honestly that wasn't even
page gap that to me was like
it was a place to cut it not even that
it was just like
this thing you could have a whole
episode about this moment itself like
this moment is so [ __ ] golden and we
had just
done some [ __ ] in the episode as you'll
see which was like over the top huge and
and got a dimer wrong and [ __ ] like that
so to then
do that one extra beat it was like save
it i remember literally being like we're
putting this in [ __ ] sex bro this is
genius that's so new because usually
when you have to cut
things from an episode it's
heartbreaking because it's stuff you
loved and nobody will ever
see it because it goes away and this it
went to this
place okay we'll tell you about some
stuff that kind of didn't make the cut
for time but
the big thing that got cut from this
episode you you still get to see
winds up we kicked it to the next one
it's like you know how like when you
were a kid and you
tell your parents like i want a dog and
the [ __ ] they're like that dog
went to the farm that dog had to go all
the way to the farm and [ __ ]
um our farm was literally the next
episode
i was like your daughter's got to go to
the farm my dog was okay
the dog left uh you know how we do this
line up your episode of uh masters of
the universe
colon revelation right now or you can
watch us
without it we'll keep it as visually
interesting as we can for two dudes
sitting [ __ ] next to each other and
stuff
i married the whole thing i think so all
right um
we'll read the script um so line it up
kids i'm about to press play now
and here we go into episode five ladies
and gentlemen
the netflix logo boo-boom we're off to
the races
um how do you let's let's do this when
did you know you were a writer
oh uh i was always writing stories and
stuff when i was a
real little kid so i think i've been
saying that i wanted to do this since i
was
six literally would tell people i wanna
like write tell
the moment i found out it was a job you
could do and that people did it at all i
i wanted to do it where did you find out
it was job what was the thing that made
you realize oh
writing is a thing i was very into uh
the the 50s black and white zorro show
that they did
and i had to know everything about it
and so i would read about it and then
you'd see who directed the episodes and
who wrote the episodes and i'm like ooh
those are real people and their names
aren't in the show it was a little bit
that and then it was a lot of it star
wars
also which is such a common answer but
but still
you know there's a reason it's a common
answer it's pretty damn powerful
there's his name ladies and gentlemen uh
written by eric carrasco how do you say
it it's me
do you do do you roll the rs you do
carrasco yeah you do you roll the yards
a little bit but i i tend to not do
yeah but you know just for ease just
because you don't want to show up
i can't believe i had to i had to open
i'm uh i'm i'm friends with griffin
newman
who voices orco and he was he was
talking about griffin
for in the writing yeah he was like
there's a guy who's great and he wants
entire team
he wants to be and he is kevin was
saying like
you know i knew the characters i knew
the world i had seen the cartoon
my touchstone was the movie but i knew
there were two people
two super fans of he-man that were my
first calls
when kevin gave me the job and i was
like
i need just tell me everything that is
special to you
about it right like what was it in the
toys or the blister cards or the
cartoons or
what was it for you and i had two
conversations one with a friend of mine
marcus perry
who went deep with me on a lot of stuff
and the other call was to griffin
he hadn't been cast i hadn't been in the
huge fan of
the of the franchise he collects the
toys he knows everything about it he
goes
really really deep on this stuff and so
i called him and i talked to griffin for
like an hour and a half
about he-man it was like we did our own
little master of the universe podcast
uh long before he was ever uh you know
called up to play orco
and and uh then i finally got assigned
the script
uh after orco is already killed so i
didn't uh didn't write any
griffin you got to write the beautiful
uh eulogy though
i did get to write i love the evil in
line where she's like you were a fool
yeah she delivers it so heartbroken that
was actually a tim sheridan pitch
the uh you're the fool i had the i had
the headstone i had adam chipping the o
we had the little bit of uh
orco scarf and i had like the rhythm of
you know you were this you were a good
friend you were this and and tim was
like
was the one who was like instead of
saying something kind about him evelyn
say you're a fool which of course has a
double meaning because of orko's
backstory and that's uh so tim sheridan
the um does that happen a lot so that
like the writers
confer behind my back yeah we were
always side
side texting make this [ __ ] better
[ __ ] we got to save this show
we moved quick when we when we broke the
story we moved really fast
it broke compared to like a supergirl uh
story breaking session or did you do
that sort of thing yeah live action tv
you got a big room full of people
you work every day you work like you
know nine to five hours or
usually ten to seven and you're taking
you know a week to break an episode one
episode
and endless debates about every little
thing
we move much fast because you have to in
live action tv you got to feed the
machine
every like nine days or something and
then there's another one that has to go
into production so here
we got to figure out the whole story
ahead of time which is always great
uh but we also that's the whole
you know run of episodes that we figured
out um and we uh we went super fast so
there was a lot of just texting to be
like is there anything that you're
planting
in your episode that i can pay off in
mine
um that's smart it's fun this is the
beginning of i mean look it's overdoses
but this is the beginning of like the
eric crossco
magic ladies and gentlemen because there
was nothing
in the outline about [ __ ] dinosaurs
it was
it was very the outline that kevin sent
us
was so it was pretty detailed until
episode five was like two sentences long
he was like go go forth you got do
something
and it was like basically here are the
big beats that have to happen in this
episode and when i first saw the draft
like it was so full of wonder and magic
like and i was used to
and one door i was used to eric's like
writing you know from supergirl and i
knew how good he was and stuff
but you know we had four scripts at that
point including my own and stuff and so
there was like all right everything's
[ __ ] firing on all cylinders this
might work and then the script for five
comes in
and it's [ __ ] dazzling and includes a
[ __ ] dinosaur hunt
um where did that come from from
paternia i
well yeah the the creatures that are in
fraternity are kind of
it's pre-turning it's prehistoric which
to be fair
in the world of masters universe mattel
it was a toy set that never came out but
the idea was preternia was eternia back
in the day
for our purposes we turned pre-ternia
into
paradise into valhalla into having the
idea that this is your
ultimate reward and some tourney of
course became our hell and stuff
so we read conned it a little bit i i
wonder if hardcore fans would be pissed
about that like right now
because it never came but it feels like
but it never happened yeah
you didn't really have the the playset
happening um it also
speaking of dc comics like it does feel
like i mean
i at least writing this one took a
little inspiration from your green arrow
run
and that was a similar like you gotta
choose to go back there's still work to
be done
we love you today a little bit thank you
for your grim jacket a little bit of
grim jacks a little bit of green arrow
that i stole the original um you went
deep even on
like you did one wundar and
who just side note last night patrick
are one of our directors
told us all that like he's like i
invented a language for the
show and we're like what he's like it's
called kudakish it's based on kudup
so he and he's like this is what it
looks like and he showed me he's like
this is yeah we were talking one day so
i wrote your name in kutakushi
and he showed me a picture of it and i
was like it looks like elvis she's
elvish
it's like the guys that like i know
that's rocky or
volcanoes yeah klingon yeah all right so
look at there's a nice little call back
there to them swinging each other around
and eric is the
just chef's kiss when it comes to
callbacks and [ __ ] like this is the
benefit of going last
because i literally called kevin
dia mark tim called everybody and was
just like what is like the thing that
you loved in your script
that i always do it if you if you get to
go last what's the thing you liked in
your script
that you would like you had a plan for
in the back of your head and you're like
i hope somebody takes this baton and
runs for it
and then you just one's worth it and you
just you just go and then it's nothing
but like satisfying payoffs which is
cool
you are my favorite episodic writer i
think
because and i've learned so much from
working with you because
like it's funny you'll hand in something
there's our camera
um voiced by the great dennis hayesburg
um you'll you'll kind of like come
in with something where i read it and
i'm like oh my god like that
that really landed well like it's almost
like he intended and then you realize
oh he's a manipulative little writer
like he knows what he's [ __ ] doing
he's
insanely clever um this made me cry when
i read the script and i
i believe i texted you and sent you a
picture of such
a hunt and the hunt ends with him
like he captures the [ __ ] beast that
he's chasing but then he's like
a goodly hunt and he lets him go he
can't be killing animals in paradise
come on
as i was reading the script i was like i
got a i got an animal loving kid
downstairs you'd be terrible don't do it
yeah
even that he stuck the landing with the
flea man joke i absolutely love
it's uh the yeah the the dinosaurs thing
came from obviously paternia
there's a real mythological thing called
the wild hunt which is what we were
pulling from
uh uh the myth of the wildland where
where odin or
a lot of cultures have it celts have it
and stuff too where when you die you get
to have this eternal hunt that's fun and
one of the questions
teddy had asked us when we were breaking
this episode is
what was adam doing in heaven like okay
so he's in heaven he wakes up what's he
been doing
what does he do and like part of that
answer was the wild time it was like
what do all these great champions of
eternia do with their time
test feats of skill and he's part of it
but
on this day he's not because he's
hanging out with his friends who come to
visit and one of our
favorite ideas going into all of this
was that when we find
adam in heaven he's adam
and he's not he-man now all the other
champions
are their more powerful selves
um or what they call their lesser selves
um
adam chose to be adam for the rest of
for all eternity that feels
like the guide to me yeah that's the
that was the fun of this episode
it was also that's why i was so happy i
got this one because it was
it weirdly like it's big and it's
climactic and huge stuff happens at the
end of it
but along the way we do just kind of get
to actually
slow it down a little bit and and and
talk um
and uh it was very rewarding that was a
delight
for for me because again like you know
it's i
like i knew the story there was an
outline but like this script
came back with [ __ ] that was not in the
outline where
i was suddenly reading a script not as
somebody going like
how's this track with what we've done or
blah blah blah or like looking at it
through a work prism
it was more just like oh my god like
[ __ ] this is
i got lost in the story i'm like they're
[ __ ] hunting dinosaurs
how imaginative i was like that's
[ __ ] crazy i was like of course they
would be hunting like dinosaurs in this
episode in heaven
in paternia like it was just so much
more magical than what was planned like
episode
what what happens at the end of episode
five was always like
[ __ ] on the books and [ __ ] but like
he's right the outline he was given was
very spartan
with the biggest point being and then
just when we think is oh
you know [ __ ] something bad happens
again and so when i got to read this
script that was like
oh my god like [ __ ] this is this guy
and it's
like it's not even like he [ __ ] went
off the rails and and told any story he
[ __ ] wanted it was all jermaine to
the conversation and beautiful
and imaginative and the idea of like
them chasing animals and [ __ ] like that
like i was like
kids will love to see this this is the
thing it it's the most fun i've had
writing
anything because you really do feel like
you're playing with action figures
there's a thing coming in future
episodes that that literally came from
a diorama i saw set up at comic-con like
there's just like
you're like oh dinosaurs are cool like
and that's the cool part about ximena is
it is very imaginative like
um yeah you can't really go wrong with
big swings
there's a robot and a sword and look at
this guy robano
is a character we haven't really talked
about that much in any of the previous
uh
one of these man but the great justin
long you know he basically gave us his
version of data
yes um and when he was doing his
performing in the booth he had his hand
on his chest
trailer just kind of funny yeah big
trailer shut up there and look how it
becomes
like the like that match yeah as the
parent are the the good folks of paris i
mean that's pat and adam right there
but um justin long's roboto
uh or just roboto in general like uh
from the jump
was a part of things and then we found a
way to tell
like a really kind of beautiful story
with the character and
like you get in this episode you get to
eulogize orco
you get to the people have already
watched the show so that if you're
watching this you're watching please
watch it for the second time if you
haven't i'm about to spoil some [ __ ] so
[ __ ] turn it off
three two one um
so i [ __ ] flubbed that count over
yeah
um gloria's bastard thank you very much
um the uh
the you know roboto goes
as well in a really poignant like
brother-sister
farewell we did two in a row right we
did and four with uh
uh orco yes that's where we start
ratcheting up the death cam
that's not three that's right i guess
i'm the most savage killer
we you and all the others the yeah the
versus killer in the animal kingdom
uh the yeah we killed we actually
we put moss man in the pilot
yes do you remember this we put moss man
in the pilot
to kill him both to announce here's what
the stakes are
skeletors turn in the the slightly
grittier reboot
that you're not in yet kids yeah and
then but the other reason we chose
mossman in particular was because he's
like a you know fraternian plant
creature in this
so that we could have him in this
episode come do a little heart-to-heart
and do a little hard time and the
heart-to-heart was beautiful i remember
reading this in the script and being
again very moving made me [ __ ] roll
it to you and stuff particularly because
we had always been talking about in the
room like you know who should play
[ __ ] moss man as alan oppenheimer
yeah
so um it's it's a really nice
moment because it's the you know moment
where he's essentially saying to adam
like
if you leave here you may just end in
dirt
like all mortals you know and but and
leave all this
[ __ ] behind dive become a forest
really and
it was so eloquently [ __ ] put
together with him being a
you know [ __ ] plant creature he's so
good too i love how he delivers this
stuff
the uh the this you got away with words
kid
everybody knows that by now thanks pat
because they've watched this
i stand next to you a lot um the what
was your favorite part of writing five
oh um i got to do i got to do a lot of
relationship stuff which was fun and we
either hadn't been
a ton of chris since the pilot because
you're he only shows up at the end of
four
and he's in flashbacks in two and three
but i got to do
the first like big adam episode since
the pilot
and it's all the relationship stuff with
tila which is
what i had the most fun doing and also
his noble side like
basically like he-man without the
muscles like adam is just a purely good
person this is why you wait uh
till five to find adam because it builds
him up as a character it builds him up
as something that that
eternia needs and it also
means that you've waited a very long
time for tila to have the kind of
closure that she wishes
she could have had because i think she
says in the episode you know
i couldn't grieve you properly i didn't
know who you were i was i wanted to be
mad at you for lying all this time but
then you're
dead so and we just knew that that's
where it was going
with uh with tila so you know
[ __ ] medallion this is the part i
mean
this this should be score i mean look we
got this amazing score by bear mccreary
but this is a thing that could easily be
scored by [ __ ]
right yeah it just seems so [ __ ]
metal man
and uh for a lot of kids look if you're
unfamiliar with the world of masters
of the universe and you're like oh i had
no idea about this
the three towers and stuff a lot of
people didn't the toy never really made
it to market and it didn't make it into
any of the shows
i don't think are we first yeah yeah
unless mike young did it there's always
throughout our process we've always been
like did mike young do it
um but i think we we may be uh the first
and that has everything to do with um
mattel because we were hired by mattel
television so
most of our master's lore and mythology
comes from
from them from their thick ass uh
books and full of material and i
remember early in the process
like when i first when you first came
over and i was like hey man you want to
work on masters of the universe with me
i had that thick ass encyclopedia yeah
and now you were like can i take this
i was like yeah go ahead i'll never use
it and then throughout the whole writing
process i kept going like where's that
[ __ ] encyclopedia
and i want to bought it to go back no
i'm glad you used it because look out
look at what you did with it it was like
a full-on crash course like i left with
a stack that i couldn't even carry
of of trades and rob david yeah rob had
written
the dc trains rob wrote i gotta give rob
woody what he likes i know what he likes
because i read what he likes yes
eric knows how to give you what you like
man he's good with him he's good with
his mouth
um tiffany's really good in this little
moment here this is the only scene where
i
there's a little bit of me in this
because eric had written some like
beautiful [ __ ]
for the death and then i just i had to
take it to the place of crying like the
mirror i was a mirror
yeah that that still breaks me up to to
this day
the idea that this guy as he [ __ ]
winds down
is finally figuring out like oh i was i
was human
i felt fear so i could feel yeah um and
it's
heartbreaking i've i've heard from so
many people who were like
[ __ ] dude even the robot died and
that was sad
and that's the performance of justin
there we go i feel that's
that's it's great oh it's so sweet
the uh and that figure i i heard
recently
is coming out in wave three he'll be
there
um now you know i should point out once
again
kids of course dealing with the realm of
sci-fi
fantasy you know people who die
don't always stay dead [ __ ] one of the
stars of this episode
is the truth got killed in the first
episode so
you know roboto this is not a spoiler or
anything like that but i'm stretching
the imagination but
roboto was an artificial construct
that's true so conceivably could
you know live again one day but
you cried for the death of a [ __ ]
robot
that could easily be it reminds me of
that ikea lamp commercial or whatever
that
the one i keep going like you idiot it's
a lamp
um this uh is the moment uh we owed io
and everybody who worked on this owes
john ostrander suicide squad creator
john ostrander and grimjack creator john
ostrander
for this moment this is my favorite uh i
i don't know if it's done enough to call
it a trope
but when a hero is in heaven
and they're like in order to help your
friends you got to go back
and they're given a choice like do i do
it because i've retained
your final reward are you gonna take the
reward or not uh
it was that was do you remember the um
the the original title which is uh maybe
a
hair pretentious the original title of
this episode was uh one is starved for
technicolor
up there explain that forge the forge on
the forest forever because
star trek city only yeah thank you thank
you i didn't do it because i like star
trek but i'm like that sounds wicked
like that's a star trek episode it tells
you the plot and it's got alliteration
so i love the title give me a hand
that's it
give me a hand what was telling about
the original title was one is star for
technicolor up there which is a quote
from
a matter of life and death um which is a
movie
sixties one of them they come out it's
an old movie uh set post war and it's a
guy
who has died but has fallen in love
right before he died
uh pilate um and he has a trial to see
if he can come back from heaven
uh and his his argument is he's in love
and love is important and it's not fair
and he needs to come back to earth and
so it was a
it's a little defending directed by the
archers yeah it's a pre-defending your
life definitely
i like that there's this little genre of
like coming out of heaven like i deserve
this i think should i live again
very fanciful notion and that's why i
always give austrian her credit cause
i'm like i'm not clever enough to think
of that but when i read that in grim
jack
that like moved me to no look at him
[ __ ] he's just an old batman he's
bruce wayne without a cow but he hasn't
he's got the cape yeah he does but it
was it like that
captured my imagination in my heart
where i was like oh my god to
have to make that decision and [ __ ] show
i did i did in my green arrow run but
you know we did it here as well you i
think of it it was an easy pack actually
think of it as yours now
because you stole it so thoroughly so
well
just the way they drew the wrapped up
sword on tila's back yes
and i love this moment just because root
i
honestly the only cat breaks my heart in
every episode he said
the only thing we could have done more
was give
like them like two more lines to each
other but we're
as you can see we're at the part of the
episode where it's like i love this the
pace of this
as i was reading the script for the
first time and i know what happens on
the last page but as i'm reading it i'm
like
oh my god you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
because he literally makes you think
everything's gonna be okay everything is
set up like a wrap up this clearly we're
almost at the denu ma
like you know there were more it really
wouldn't feel like we did a five episode
mini series and we're like oh here's the
sword everything's
right with the world and it wasn't
intended to be like we dropped five and
then we dropped another five
i don't remember what the plan ever was
but i thought it was like
all ten at once but then they decided to
split it up
and it split nicely it ended up
splitting because
it was a real like oh a seasoned
cliffhanger because when you plant it
you do want you know
you want your three extras you had the
last travel line other than i have the
power was like
still know the tune you know some things
you can never forget they used in the
trailer
writers like that yeah as we wrote that
few times it was like
that's one of my i mean uh but i
remember when i
i gave the script to you or to somebody
to
give me notes and i was like i i want
this line in here it's such a trailer
like i know it's going to end up in the
trailer because it's
it's a nostalgia show like it's like
some things you never forget i was like
this is gonna end up in the trailer
isn't it but like i really just
it wasn't that's never the motivation
and it shouldn't if you're writing at
home
don't just write toward the trailer
lines don't write what's best for the
story
the more you know so i was not doing
that but i did write and go like ooh
this does have like a double
meaning nostalgia it worked out
incredibly nicely look at all this [ __ ]
right now you're just like
oh everything's gone back to normal what
a great journey we went on
it's so pretty too adam's back you know
and he he's adam's got the sword so
clearly he-man's about to come back this
[ __ ] looks like it's out of disney when
the flowers pop out and [ __ ]
boys did such a nice job um and
everything feels
rap uppy and then you know
yeah i like that we have positive
associations with the skull coming back
like normally it's like oh pretty castle
turns into skulls should be bad
for us it's like turning into a skull i
was like yay everything's back to
everything's ugly
yeah and then oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] kids now this was like you know
[ __ ]
in the outline in the writers room it
was always like
squelching sound that's a great little
thing and the
blood dripping out and stuff but the
notion was always like
we thought of you guys throughout this
look at that
reaches down takes the [ __ ] sword and
then kicks him off the [ __ ] havoc
staff
i do like yeah for anybody that was just
off for a second oh man this show's woke
hey man wake the [ __ ] up what just
happened it was one of the most metal
[ __ ] things i've ever seen in my life
these two never stabbed each other but
it's payback yeah any man stabbed him
[ __ ] skeletor that call back from the
pilot that uh you finally used it for
what it's intended for
um this is i love moments like this too
where the [ __ ] villain tells you a
bunch of [ __ ] yeah
and he doesn't stop looking at the
camera by the way because i did finally
get like
sucked into the episode now i'm just
like watching it
this is such a sad moment and i hated it
in the script i loved it
[ __ ] but i hated the moment where she's
like i was really starting to like you
kids that's such like an 80s movie line
eric's eric writes like like the movies
we went to see in the 80s
like good there's actually beads uh i
just love i feel bad for her i always
felt bad for her
and it's such a like she bonded she
crosses the line and beastman is just
like good to have you back well that
beast man
i'm not in trouble am i he's kind of
playing both sides
i always love that i'm sorry and you are
um
i like that he calls her captain i love
i like star wars
he that andra like gets it look at my
face child is me
um i jumped in there it was it was
beautiful but i was like oh my god i
love marcus voice and i just want him to
chew the scenery
we called this you and i when we were
passing the script back and forth we
kept calling it like his richard the
third monologue
because he's talking about how ugly he
is and he's always been cast as the
villain
because all our references now as much
as they're like superman the movie and
stuff they're also like we were
literally like it's gonna be richard the
third
there's a lot of couldn't help ourselves
a lot of influence yeah
um this is uh you know we felt like oh
we were all so happy in the writer's
room like oh my god
so he gets the sword finally because
that was kind of the point
of the journey was like to get the sword
into skeletor's hand
so that we he could be master of the
universe and then what happens
so this episode kind of like with diaz
episode where
episode one was too large and a bunch of
[ __ ] went into
episode two episode six
as we were talking about before has this
amazing
like beat it went longer than episode
five went longer it went like
yeah it's already maybe one or two
scenes long i didn't realize that the
first time i saw it so it was a little
bit
a little extra it i mean i don't want to
spoil it because we do it in
six and stuff but it kept going and
stuff um
but that his stuff was so [ __ ] good
that it seeded
episode six and so eric wrote like half
or
for the first quarter of episode six and
then i jumped in because he was working
on something else and stuff
and that was honestly one of the first
times i've ever like really co-wrote
with somebody yeah it was an honor it
was
i mean not an honor but it was just it
was good and fun and [ __ ] and it was so
it was weird i mean other writers must
feel it but let's it's like
oh i don't need that other muscle
because we that muscle's stronger yeah i
mean we kind of
we did a lot of improv writing on the
supergirl episodes because he would just
be on set
and then if you have kevin on set he can
just be like oh i'm gonna try one like
this and then give you some
great [ __ ] line of dialogue uh and uh
can we say that just cursed don't get
great oh yeah [ __ ] yeah
i didn't realize if we were uh christine
diaz unless diaz mother's watching feel
free to curse great
awesome uh but yeah so we we did a lot
of like
collaborating that's kind of writing-ish
but this is the first time it was like
pages were passed back and forth
and then not the last then not the last
time then we went and got a big jump now
going into the next five um eric and i
wrote six but did you write another one
before 10
no so just 10. and 10 is like 10
is the five of the back half
where you're just like holy [ __ ] and not
only that
but he has to land the [ __ ] thing too
and tie all the strings together it's
fun to go last you're just paying off
stuff
now i'm understanding yeah i don't
understand but but eric was
chosen to be the cleanup hitter for that
reason it's just like oh my god five is
so amazing
eric's writing [ __ ] ten so wait until
you see that but what you'll get to see
first
is a bunch of six and [ __ ] that that
you'll i i ain't gonna spoil it here but
that [ __ ]
there's a there's an atom you want to
spoil it
i've been wanting to tell yourself it's
so good this is the hard part of these
commentaries i was like
i wrote this in 2019 like animation
takes
so long because it has to look as
beautiful as this and mercifully they
took what time they did because
powerhouse knocked out
we were just sitting there like you know
[ __ ] jerking each other off writing
scripts having a good time
powerhouse literally turned it into a
[ __ ] cartoon and everything that
takes you 10 seconds to write
you know months and iterations and years
are you sure you want this i'm like yeah
i think it works in the story
i mean if not we can cut it they're like
yeah but but can we please yeah can we
cut it now rather than go through the
process and stuff
um wonderful partners wonderful
collaborators it all starts with the
word ladies and gentlemen and the word
is eric we don't get where we get to go
with masters of the universe colon
revelation
without this revelation right here thank
you for making it so much [ __ ] better
than it would have been if you didn't do
it
stop um we did another writing thing
later on that was nothing to do
man talk about it yeah we can't it's our
lips are sealed but yes
kevin's the the best boss you can
possibly have
not only is this very much his [ __ ] so
good i didn't know that i was the boss
well that's because we were texting on
the screen yeah they were all going
around can you believe this yes uh no
he's just doing john ostrander again
not only is this much more your vision
than you would lead people to believe
uh you ran the room you'd be killed by
those [ __ ] empty wolf
you're right there don't don't throw me
under the bus it was his idea too
i i'm the sjw yes all right yeah the
you're a great boss you ran the room
super super well that's my first one
you got everybody to give that little
extra i you know like
everybody is giving it their all
everybody's turned it up to 11. but
also you know i've never written
anything for somebody who will
text you photos of themself crying like
i think that a lot so we'll text you
pictures and like like i liked this one
line or i got this moment and he like
live
texts you you get the commentary
from the script stage before any of it
has been drawn and it was that was
so rewarding one of my favorite things
to do is sit down with your script
and and [ __ ] screenshot
lines and text them to you and be like
this
oh my god this is fantastic and then i
got to do it with you
on the on on six and also on the other
the other
thing we can't talk about we have to be
like mutual appreciation society
can you tell but um but yes i mean look
i'm suffering
people like you you're so great they
both like each other so much and they
both suck so hard
i for me it's a big deal though because
i said you know indie right or indie
lone wolf [ __ ] like that
and so my whole career is predicated on
like me my ideas
um i remember this is a terrible example
and i'm certainly not comparing myself
to the guy but i i'm just going to pull
a film history example
when woody allen sorry
okay all right wait wait let me see if i
can land and hold on
did bullets over broadway and he
co-wrote it
yes with somebody else woody allen was
known for like just doing woody allen
and stuff and then he co-wrote bullets
and bullets was
fantastic yeah and so he got refreshed
by doug whatever his [ __ ] name was
um and i think they were not oscar
oscar-nominated
that's what writing with you like
reminds me of where i'm like
oh [ __ ] just when i've gotten long in
the tooth i'm the one who's not woody
allen yeah you're not the way to go
and look for the records neither am i
neither of us or woody i like we should
say that not like woody and buzz
but yeah yeah but they didn't write
everything together because one of those
guys was conservative and the other
guy's real liberal i guess
it's not yet can't get away from it yeah
it's everywhere
ladies and gentlemen this has been the
masters of the universe revelation
celebration a celebration of the writers
of master the
masters of the universe of revelation
and then when i say that out loud it's a
celebration of the revelation
but it also sounds very likely you just
[ __ ] celebrating yourselves was
you guys just jerking each other off yes
that's what we did and hopefully
you got a little on you if you're here
watching it for the second time for the
commentary track he probably liked it
you you're cucking this out you like it
or you're like you're hate watching us
and you just want to go i'll take it
either way
ah there it is ladies and gentlemen four
masters of the universe revelation
celebration i'm kevin smith
i'm eric carrasco remember kids uh we'll
see you for the next five whenever
netflix drops them but until then
you have the power
this is the cat greetings everybody
and welcome to the aka ask of anything
every saga has a ten year anniversary
ladies and gentlemen and this
is what happens with jay and sam bob get
old i'm kevin smith